Y no sentía dolor. No, no es verdad. Dios me castigó.
¿Ahorita usted me entiende?
¿Tiene algunas preguntas? Tengo mucho que explicarle a usted. Muchísimo.
Me deja un poquito de descansar.
Yo quiero, y usted me disculpa, que me explique qué vio en Sobibor.
¿Cómo eran los lugares? ¿Qué vio en el tiempo que estuvo ahí?
Era un bosque, árboles muy bajos, y cortaron todos los árboles.
Eso era retirado por completo de Sobibor. Sobibor era un pueblo, un pueblo grande.
Era 13 kilómetros de Ciudad de los Ojos.
¿Y cómo era el lugar? ¿Cuántos lagers? ¿Tenía lagers? ¿Tenía crematorios?
¿Qué vio usted? Allá todo fue construido.
¿Qué es lo que vio usted?
Todo allá fue construido, que yo te dije, mire, gentes que llevaron cien.
No era quemar el crematorio, era con yeso.
Después, mire, cuando llevaron más, ayudaron a construir por obligación.
No quisieron hacerlo, pero usted sabe cómo para uno, un minuto de vida, vale mucho.
Usted me preguntó, ¿no duró más que un día?
Me dice que cada segundo era un año.
¿Qué me queman? ¿No quieren sufrir más? Que yo sé que yo me voy a quemar.
¿Qué piensa uno en ese momento?
Yo estaba seguro conmigo que a mí no me pueden quemar.
¿Adónde viene esa fuerza? No sé.
Quiero que me describa cómo era el lugar.
Yo digo usted, era un gran terreno.
Cercada, mire, con luces así cada dos metros.
Todos los alambres arriba electricizados, que ya no puede salir nada.
Nadie.
¿Dónde lo metieron a usted? ¿Dónde estaba usted?
En ese terreno. El tren. Entraron adentro del terreno.
Allá, mire, salieron de vagones y el tren hizo vuelta y salió.
Entraron y salieron.
¿Y usted se quedó adónde?
En ese terreno.
Adónde estaba el crematorio.
100 metros de horno.
¿Cómo era el horno? ¿Lo vio por fuera?
Adentro, no estuvo adentro.
Yo estuve adentro, yo no estoy aquí.
¿Qué es lo que vio desde afuera? ¿Cómo era la construcción?
Era, mire, ¿sabe una cosa?
Como entrar, mire, cuando se hace de un tanque de concreto.
¿Usted me entiende? Alto.
¿Y qué era adentro? No puede usted decir.
¿Grande, pequeño?
Muchísimo grande. Largo.
Que no podía dominar con la vista, es largo.
Altura de 3 metros más o menos.
Entre 3 y 4 metros de altura.
¿Qué más tenía? ¿Era cuadrado? ¿Tenía...?
No.
Por ejemplo, vamos a decir, desde pared allá.
¿Usted me entiende?
Me dice ese tamaño.
¿Qué era adentro?
¿Y arriba era todo plano?
Placa, placa.
Placa de concreto.
¿Qué color era el lugar?
¿Las paredes?
Concreto.
De cemento.
¿Cómo era adentro?
No puede usted decir.
Ahorita puede decir.
¿De su vivir?
No puede decir. Nada.
No me entiendo.
¿Usted quiere saber cómo era el crematorio?
Cuando yo fui libertado...
No hablemos de eso todavía.
No, no, no. Yo tengo que explicarlo.
Yo tengo que contestar que usted me pregunta, señorita.
Era otro crematorio en Majdanek, Lublin.
Allá, yo fui libertado en el año 44,
la noche de junio.
Yo con un amigo me agarraron un ruso,
me dieron tres botellas vodka,
y se me ofrecieron para el crematorio Majdanek.
Allá se me contaron cómo era el crematorio.
En Majdanek era redondo.
Mucho tamaño.
Y era...
Como entra para hacer contestaciones,
marchas para países. ¿Usted me entiende?
Adentro...
Allá metieron gente con hipojarmas adentro,
y se me contaron todo.
Huesos, polvo,
los alemanes no tenían tiempo
para licitar eso.
Era dos caminos.
¿Usted vio ese lugar? ¿Lo vio?
Yo con mi amigo, con mis propios...
Me dieron todo.
Era un canal de un kilómetro,
que no tenía tiempo para caminar.
Cabeza aquí,
cabeza aquí,
pies aquí y pies aquí.
Cuando todavía no tenían tiempo para cerrar,
¿usted me entiende?
Usted pensaba que esas gentes viven.
Eso yo lo vi en Majdanek.
Segundo crematorio Majdanek, Lublin.
Usted vio de Lublin.
Usted vio de Majdanek el crematorio.
Esto, yo con mi amigo, que ya murió,
con los pocos ojos.
Y allá agarraron a todos los jefes alemanes,
que trabajaban allá,
y cerraron con hambre.
En siete días.
Era un juicio.
Y mataron a ellos.
Estaban allá nosotros, con mi amigo.
Nosotros estamos muriendo.
No, hay que revivir.
Fueron...
¿Cómo se dice?
Orcados, ¿no?
Entraron en camiones.
Tenían en el cuello
esas cosas, y caían.
El camión se fue, y se quedaron aquí.
Ahí está el crematorio.
Aquí era redondo.
Ahí era redondo.
¿Dónde estuvo usted?
¿A usted lo querían meter?
¿Y qué es lo que no funcionaba?
Una pieza, ¿no?
Sí.
¿Dónde estuvieron mientras estaban...?
¿Qué os digo? Estaban todos sentados.
¿En el suelo?
En el suelo.
Y cuando salió el sol,
yo estaba sentado al frente, donde entró...
Usted explicó.
Donde entró el primer jefe del crematorio,
Old Summer.
Cuando él viene siempre a mi cerradera,
que yo doy madera para puentes.
¿Usted no me entiende?
Él era el jefe.
¿Y qué comentaba la gente mientras esperaban?
Mudo.
Yo tampoco no hablaba.
Yo puro que me sentaba, mire, con manos,
como mi señora me dijo, mire...
¿Por qué tienen a nosotros...?
¿Por qué ya no terminan con nosotros?
¿Por qué no terminan?
¿Sabe?
Un segundo era un año para vivir.
¿Y qué...?
¿Qué puede usted pensar, mire?
Ya usted sabe que usted está ya...
Está en vivo o muerto.
¿Qué puede pensar usted?
¿Y vio a otra persona que estaba en los lugares de trabajo?
Conmigo estaba, mire, el rabino.
Dalí Quedadete.
Todo el mundo sabe de él.
Cuando pasó la guerra del 39,
se fue para Varsovia,
y primera bomba que bombardearon Varsovia,
él huyendo para un búnker,
mataron a él.
Con hijo de él,
Méndale,
se llamaba.
También era rabino.
Con dos hijos.
Estaba conmigo junto.
Y él me llamó.
Conocí de la misma edad.
Me quedé.
Y dice que me haya.
Vamos a hacer el último rezo antes de morir.
Ya yo no veo, mire, nada en el mundo.
Ya yo veo a mi padre.
Ya yo veo a mi abuelo.
Ya yo veo todo lo que sabe usted de Talmud,
que está en otro mundo estudiando Talmud.
¿Sabe qué le dijo?
Yo sé que voy a utilizar últimas palabras
de las oraciones de la vida.
No hagas Méndale.
Y en estos momentos,
no adónde vino la fuerza mía,
y adónde vino eso,
no puedes.
A mí no me van a matar.
Entonces, ¿cuánta gente había allí esperando por eso?
Con usted.
Te pregunto eso.
¿Cuánta gente estaba con usted
mientras esperaban que esa pieza, que...
Yo digo usted, mire,
nosotros nos trataron a las 10 de la noche,
sábado de la noche.
Sábado de la noche.
Y se me estaban antes las 9 de la mañana allá.
¿Cuántas personas estaban allí?
Yo digo usted,
en Talmud, 30 eran más o menos,
cálculo mío, no puedo decir,
1.000 más o 2.000 menos,
más o menos, era cálculo,
como 40.000 personas.
Si eran 30, si eran 35,
yo no puedo usted decir exactamente.